ever there seems to be new shots fired
and a Katy Perry Taylor Swift war all
Nancy there is bad blood still boiling
Katy just released a new duet with Nicki
Minaj that sure feels like a one-two
punch at miss Swift UK miss you don't
have to look too deep to see the shade
the song's title swish wish is just two
letters away from Swift swish swish
swish Katy also represents a tiger not
losing sleep over a shellfish or a
sheepy yeah we all remember roar and how
about this video Taylor posted of
herself and wait for it sheep Katie says
your calculated that's a word critics
have used to describe Taylor in the past
and a word Swift herself says she hates
as the Katie versus Taylor saga
continues Tay Tay's ex Harry Styles may
be on the receiving end of some bad
blood himself
Stiles did carpool karaoke last night
with James Corden
but his One Direction bandmate Liam
Payne who just released his debut single
today said this Harry song is not
something I'd I'd listen to but I think
he did a great job of doing what he
wanted to do
Liam fires off another slam in the song
no I used to be Mundy comma and if you
think Harry's bothered think again cuz
he's got his pal court
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]